hello everyone welcome to the beautiful
Pacific Northwest of the United States
of America it's great to be here in come
home and awesome to hear in the middle
of a beautiful sunrise and some folding
right outside my windows here thanks for
letting me borrow the Sun for a bit I
know Richard Campbell is over in
conference room three a few hundred
kilometers north of me also experiencing
that sunrise
so I'm Matt Ferguson mess hall listen as
we say in Denmark and I'm the lead
designer on c-sharp language at
Microsoft and today we're going to talk
about language design because that's
what I know to talk about so I have a
few things cued up in my slides here
that I will try to actually successfully
click on there we go
this I want to talk about some of the
some of the features that are probably
more interesting or or different than
what people used to when that's just
shipped a couple of months ago one that
is queued up for the next release and
some thoughts for for its further into
the future of c-sharp now I was in the
the quiz that the NBC social last night
and I almost wanted and what bothers me
is not the bottle of whiskey that I
didn't win it's the fact that I flunked
the question about which programming
language was named after a TV series so
to redeem myself I sprinkle in a few
quotes from that franchise throughout
that hopefully are relevant to the topic
so to start out with let's talk about
nullable reference types which is a
feature that shipped in c-sharp eight
and has been out now for four or five
months in release so the the sort of
core issue that
Noble reference types are there to help
address is really the elephant in the
room of object-oriented programming for
the past fifty years are just one of
them it can be more than one elephant
and that's that's the problem with null
so we've sort of all just accepted the
fact that null is a valid value of any
object type so an all is a person null
is a vehicle null is an animal not as
any is anything you might want it to be
and of course that that causes problem I
have a tiny little program here and if I
run it then it's trivial what it does I
create a person I get the length of
their middle name using a helper
function and then I write that length
out and there's nothing the compiler
doesn't complain it doesn't give any
cause for concern but when I run the
program of course you get one of the
famous monty python explosions followed
by and now for something completely
different so it's taking a little while
because i'm proceeding so things take
longer when you're presenting but let's
see here you go get that beautiful red
telling us that something is wrong we
get the and we get the thing in the
debugger telling us that there was a
null reference exception the middle
variable was null oh because I don't
actually have a middle name and I was
trying to take the length of it and now
the program crashed so wouldn't it be
nice if the compiler could have warned
me a little bit about something like
that happening in my code and that's
what all the reference types are about
so essentially the idea with all the
reference types is that it's a whole big
feature probably the crowning jewel of
c-sharp a that's all about making fewer
things work
it's not a new thing that makes more
things work but is it's a feature that
will tell you when your program is
probably it's probably wrong in more
places than it has previously and so
it's gonna give you more it's going to
talk more smack at you and give you more
warnings or errors and so therefore it's
a feature that you have chopped it up
into so let's go and have a look at that
so here's that person class that we were
using looks very innocent again and I
use that to argument structure there too
to build one of them before but if we go
and turn on the nullable reference types
checking we can huh nullable enable it's
a new directive and t-shirt then it'll
start telling you something is suspect
or suspect with respect to nulls so you
see I get a warning on the prison
constructor here saying that middle name
is uninitialized and it's non null Abal
so it shouldn't be it should be
initialized huh well I can initialize it
middle name equals no ha there I've
initialized it sure enough the morning
goes away but now I get a different
morning saying you can't assign null to
a none null reference type so
essentially by training on this feature
I've said that all the reference types
in c-sharp are now none nullable and we
will warn you if you try to put a null
into them or leave an all in them as I
did to start out with and that is really
there that is the first half of trying
to address the null problem I'm
essentially just don't let your stick
nulls on there no nulls anywhere unless
you explicitly ask for it so how do you
explicitly ask for it you ask well you
can have an nullable reference types
which is the name of the feature and you
can put the question mark syntax now on
reference types we've had that on value
types in c-sharp for years and years but
now the reference type can also be
nullable and now we're declaring to the
world that middle names can be null and
now we're allowed to put the null
in there without incident but let's go
and have a look at what happened in our
program now now because we declared
middle name to be a type string question
mark and now we grab it out here the
type inference infers here that the vara
is a string question mark and therefore
we're not allowed to dot it so I'm
getting protected here so how can I but
how can i how can I help how can I get
around this morning
well the old-fashioned way of doing that
in c-sharp would be to check for null
first if middle equals no or as we say
nowadays you can say middle is null then
return zero maybe and now you can see
the warning goes away on them on the
middle dot length down here because we
do control flow analysis to see that if
you get to this point in the code then
middle cannot be null
because if it was we would have branched
out already off the method here so
essentially the way that you deal with
nullable reference types and avoid the
warnings is just to do the null checking
that you've done all along and and we're
very smart about recognizing when you
are when you're doing various forms of
null checking we could also have said we
could have checked it in a completely
different way we can say return middle
question dot length well that gives you
a nullable int it gives you null if the
length was if the middle was null
otherwise it gives you the length but
that we can alter less it so that if it
hoped that whole thing is no then you
return zero instead and again the
warnings go away so that's the that's
the essence of the Melville reference
types feature so when you add something
like that to an old language there's
bound to be these gray areas we we can
just handle everything so we try to
handle as much as
but there are some places where we just
we don't want to warn because it's not a
nice thing you could have done instead
for instance you create an array of
strings
you're not going to warn you to saying
that oh well these strings you created
and all so a few places where the fact
that this is grafted onto an existing
language and intended to be turned on on
your existing code means that we made
some trade-offs that it's not entirely
safe but it'll get the vast majority of
the places in your code where where you
might get these non-reference exceptions
and it's really helped us fix this one
so this is a this is a point in the talk
where I would encourage you if you have
questions on this on this feature click
them in slide them that should be there
should be a link next to where the
streams is coming at you going to slide
oh and and ask your questions there and
I will wait for a suitable amount of
time to see if they show up
while we're waiting for them while we're
waiting for the questions to come in one
thing that you might observe here is
that this is actually sort of a little
bit unsafe in a way right that it's not
so bad here but let's say that I didn't
have this this local variable here this
temporary variable for the middle name
but I was actually oh hang on can i it's
not working
I can inline the temporary variable here
[Music]
and that's actually fine but if but
let's say that the middle name changes
between south this is where let's see
let's say that the middle name changes
between the the assignment and the test
so let's say that I said yeah that's
actually this is where I want to inline
the temporary variable sorry for the
confusion here let's say that I fixed
the warning like so if Peter middle name
it's no with trans ero now you see the
warning goes away because the analysis
assumes that the that Peter middle name
stays the same between the test and the
and the dotting here that's not actually
entirely reliable right there might be
multiple threads or some other code
might be changing the middle name of
this object behind the scenes that the
analysis of this method can't see so
we're making some optimistic assumptions
that vocationally may be wrong and
that's again part of finding the balance
with more there are some features that
are more safe by construction than
others and certainly the ways in which
you can not reference p-type middle name
twice but kind of grab it right away
into a temporary variable that no one
else has access to those are more safe
by construction now we have a question
on this one which is you know how would
you go about enabling this nullable
check in a big old solution with many
projects yes so the way it's enabled is
that you can either enable it for the
whole project with a with a project
setting which I hope that we can turn on
by default in new projects starting
maybe already as soon as done at 5:00
and but you can also as you saw me do in
the person class and that's what I did
in the program before I even started I
did that in the
in the project with the the program in
here but I hadn't turned it on for the
project that has the class in it instead
I can you can turn it on per file with
these directives and you can even like
turn it on for part of a file so I can
take this nullable enable and I can put
it down here and now you can see that
the I get a warning on the question mark
because the features not turned on for
the first half of the file you turn it
on and off or there are various ways
that you can carve out the pieces that
are currently features currently applied
to and so one way of doing this is to
use these mechanisms to gradually
introduce nullable reference types to
your code base a bit at a time there may
be some code bases that I that are just
very well tested and you're not really
worried about them having no problems in
themselves but there may be a library
they may be a library that other code
bases rely on and so you can also choose
to offer inaudible annotations but not
do the null checking inside of your own
body if you go your own code if you
trust the code itself to define though
these various ways that you can do
gradual adoption but it is so it is a
hump to get over to get existing code to
to pinned all annotated and all aware if
you will and let me try to provide these
these ways of managing that what we are
doing is we're rolling out nullable
across all the core libraries and we're
encouraging people who offer libraries
from that aren't from Microsoft to also
do the same so that when you rely on
other people's API is the libraries you
will get those nullable annotations in
the signatures and and you can you can
get better feedback on how you use those
libraries in your own code so
once you if you turn it on on a new
project though then it keeps you honest
all the time it comes just one more
piece of feedback that you get from the
tooling and so there it's kind of smooth
it's only when you're sort of going
through the bulk update if you choose to
do so that's the harder what could be a
reason not to enable this feature if
you're able to use t-shirt in a new
project there's really not a good reason
the feature is very non obnoxious in new
code the only reason I can think of to
not use it in new code is if if a live
library you rely on heavily hasn't
adopted it yet you you have the choice
of either still using the feature but
then you might get more warnings when
the next version of the library gets its
nullable annotations or in that case you
might choose to wait until your
dependencies about have adopted it
before you do so you don't get to churn
that's sort of the only reason I can
think of so that should be sort of
temporary in the next within the next
year or two hopefully most of the world
most of the active code and active
libraries out there are not aware how
would this help when not implicitly
assigning all but rather the value being
derived from an expression that could
return all I external library well it
helps because the type of those
libraries will say whether the thing can
be naal or not and we will defensively
say oh that thing might be null then we
will warn if you if you do reference it
unsafely without checking first of
course if you rely on a library that
hasn't been annotated yet you won't get
any warnings and so it doesn't help you
if you're relying on a library that
hasn't been all annotated that's that's
really where the boundary is and again
we could have made sort of the safe
choice here and say well if you use an
old library that's not annotated we're
going to warn you all over the place and
that's probably very that's not very
conducive to adoption and so we said
instead that old code non-null aware
code
where the feature hasn't turned on those
libraries they get a pass they don't
trigger any warnings in user code so it
doesn't really help you there okay um
and then I think that was mostly it for
the novel reference types and we've got
through the questions so I will go back
to the slides and stairs like deck here
again now is something completely
different so training away from what's
already out there and heading into the
future of c-sharp one of the things that
we have been looking at for a very very
long time and we sort of hinted oh we're
almost there we almost figured this out
is a feature that we affectionately
called Wreckers or a set of features or
a kind of feature idea if you will the
idea is in c-sharp as a classic
object-oriented programming language
writing simple data types can be pretty
laborious because all the defaults
sometimes are kind of poking the wrong
way and we we want to find some ways to
make this easier um so it started out
with okay we can we can build a feature
that lets you write a very abbreviated
syntax and then it it's opinionated and
it sort of just generates all the right
stuff for some value of that but every
time we've looked at it like that it
that hasn't really panned out to be a
very nice feature or it's one of those
where as soon as you don't fit within
the opinionated Ness of that feature you
fall off a cliff and you have to write a
whole bunch of code yourself so
we've been searching for is a way to
kind of kind of like if you remember
link language integrated query in
c-sharp 3 or you know about it
it it wasn't really one feature so much
as it was a set of features that kind of
work together to achieve a certain
scenario but also a valuable features in
and of themselves and we're trying to
think of records in the same way and so
I'll show you where our thinking is
today with no promises that this is how
it will ship in actual c-sharp 9 but
we're hoping to ship seizure at 9 late
this fall along with night 5 in November
and so we're hopefully converging on
this there's still some open questions
and you'll see some of those so one of
the things that we that we've try to do
intermittently for a while is to better
support immutable data types as opposed
to mutable so there are several ways in
which if you want to write immutable
data type you're at a disadvantage in
c-sharp and we'll continue to deal with
some of those and I'll show you that in
a bit
we also want to better support what we
call nominal creation or what we started
calling nominal creation and essentially
think of it as using object initializers
instead of or on top of constructors
because it has a bunch of good
properties and people use them a lot and
there are a few other things here but
we'll get to them in a minute but one of
the big points here is that we want to
have all these features work well with
inheritance and that turns out to be
because inheritance is a key feature in
c-sharp and records feature isn't really
worth its salt in an object or in a
programming language if it isn't robust
across inheritance and and hat it
doesn't have like a good conceptual
founding even when you have inheritance
hierarchies things that derived from
each other
so that's been one of the things that
has been really important for us to work
out before we before we go public with
this feature so let's let's dive in and
have a look let's start out with them
nominal creation so
classically this is sort of as opposed
to positional creation so so classically
object on the programming languages like
Java and so on they have constructor
classes have constructors does the
person class here it has a constructor
that takes the data that eventually
becomes the properties so you have to
write the constructor you have to assign
to the properties at least to share it
you used to also manually write a
backing field and and and the logic to
surface the backing field through the
property and now we at least have Auto
properties to deal with that but it
still you have to do this transformation
work here and then when you when you
write the derived class it gets a little
more annoying because you have to take
the parameters for the base class as
well as your your additional state here
and pass some of it up to the base class
explicitly and then do the rest you now
contrast that with how you would do it
with object initializes which have been
able to do in C shirt since C sharp 3
you would just write a class like this
two properties and that's it and the
drive class derives and then has another
property and that's it and now the place
where it gets a little more laborious is
that instead of just passing values to a
essentially a creation function
constructor well you have to do it
nominally by name instead of by position
here so that your you're directly
setting the properties as part of your
construction expression here instead of
passing them into a function that then
does something with them that happens to
always be the same thing pretty much so
clearly there's just some terse Ness
benefits to the nominal creation part
but there are also other benefits from a
software engineering perspective in
particular if you think about these
chunks of code the base class the drive
class the the consuming client of the
code
think of them being independent living
in different projects different
assemblies and and evolving may be to
some degree independently there are all
kinds of there are all kinds of strong
dependencies in the in the positional
regime here where let's say I wanted to
add another property to a person now I
have to I I can't just add another
parameter to the constructor because now
I'm going to break the derived class and
I'm gonna break the construction here
now I could I could maybe add it with a
with an optional parameter but that's
still binary breaking change or now I
have to keep a constructor around that
it's not really the one I'm supposed to
use anymore just so that my other code
doesn't break so it's the whole
independent updates thing becomes very
gnarly it's your very strong
dependencies between both at the source
and the binary level between the
different components here and contrast
that over here we're really as long as
the members that I'm talking about are
still there the code will still compile
so a lot of a lot of people I talk to
they use the mandate this nominal
approach to to class libraries and say
we don't we're not going to do the
constructor based thing at all even
though that sort of is the official way
in the language service fee for the
because of these software engineering
benefits now of course the big downside
is that it works by actually assigning
to the properties as part of the after
the object has been created so under the
hood it creates a student then assigns
into these properties which means that
they have to be mutable and so if you
want to have immutable data
representations which you often do when
you're just simply representing data
simply or have a an immutable data model
like the syntax trees in a Rosslyn
compiler for c-sharp for instance are
immutable and many things nowadays are
done with immutable models
well having to make your object model
mutable just so that you can use object
initializes that seems like it's um it's
a serious disadvantage and so one of the
features we're looking at is what we're
calling in it only properties and that's
the idea is that you can create a
version of the property setter that only
works during initialization time and so
we're we're creating ascension to this
concept of initialization time which is
which stretches beyond the actual
constructor call and also includes the
stuff that's in the object initializer
here so so these properties are
assignable until the until the object
initializer stops and then no longer so
now you're sort of regaining
immutability while being able to use
nominal object creation that's one
feature now one thing you lose with
nominal object creation is this ability
to do whole object validation and other
initialization logic that kind of
depends on having all the data available
to some logic that says oh this object
can't be created because this is that or
that does some last-minute
initialization or something so in a
positional regime you would put some
logic in the constructor here and say ok
I'm gonna check that the you know they
join the length of this name all told
isn't isn't too great otherwise he'll
throw an exception whereas for the the
nominal stuff there isn't really a place
to put this check because by the time
the constructor runs you haven't
assigned the first name and the last
name yet that is yet to come that is yet
that happens during the execution of the
initializers so we're thinking of this
idea we've called the validators but
they should probably be called
initializers or something many things
are already called initializers so we'll
think of a good name for them but the
idea is that it's something like a
constructor
it doesn't take any parameters it
doesn't have any accessibility defined
or anything it's just a chunk of code
that a class can declare that gets run
after initialization so it's the last
stuff that gets run so here it would get
run after the object initializes had
already been assigned and it can now
examine the well this should be
uppercase later first name and last name
let's bug in my slide there you now
examine the state of the object and
decide whether this is a good object to
share with the world before it gets a
sign and sort of has this last chance of
throwing an exception just before this
object has been completed and gets
assigned to P and shared with the world
and and consumed so it's sort of the
last chance to get in a at a check or
some other initialize the logic here so
so that's another way in which we're
trying to make nominal creation more
full-fledged
one thing that we haven't gotten so far
looking at yet is no one's forcing you
to assign these properties that are
declared here whereas with the
positional if you are if your
constructors parameters aren't optional
then you are forced to pass something in
sometimes you want that you want
something to be mandatory and we're
still looking at what's the what's the
right feature for letting properties be
mandatory to have mandatory
initialization so it's working progress
now those things aren't about records
but we'll that's a separate feature yet
they're just like useful features in
c-sharp and here's one more that might
be moderately useful in and of itself
but we're sort of starting to gather up
a set of building blocks for having a
dedicated records feature again just
like link there are all these building
blocks lambdas and expression trees and
so on and then there's the actual career
expression feature that brings them all
together now
thing that that is frequently annoying
to people is that you can only really
create objects with constructors if you
want to apply an object initializer like
down here you can only apply it in a new
expression you can have like a call like
a factory method and then apply an
object initializer so it's hard for a
class to offer a more abstract view of
its object creation options really now
let's say that we had some way of naming
something in factory then we we could
allow you to apply object initializes to
the result of a factory and the factory
in turn would have to promise that it
will only return new objects and we
could check that so assume that we have
that feature let me try to to to do one
one thing that you could do if you had
that so let's add to the person class
let's give it a protective essentially a
copy constructor a constructor that
takes an existing person and copies its
state over to a new to this new person
okay its protective so it's only meant
to be called from inside the class
itself and now we put a public virtual
method out there and the surface area of
person called with takes no parameters
and all it does is it creates an new
copy of this person and returns it and
this we can whether it's an if an
attribute or an actual keyword we can
discuss since axis always up for
discussion but because it's marked a
factory method he it satisfies that
criterion because it is retraining a new
object and compiler can check this and
we can do the same kind of thing in
student and you can override the with
method and return student instead of a
person and actually maybe we can add
crowberry and return types to see
sheriff as well and we're working on
doing that properly in runtime as it's a
separate feature again so that you can
have a more specific return type when
you
override a method than the one that that
was in the original declaration so now
we are all riding with two actual
returning student instead of a person so
that the width method essentially gives
you a copy of what the object actually
was not a copy at the sort of static
aesthetically known type okay what's
with this whiff method well if I had
that and it's a factory method then I
could do this I could call the width
method get a copy bag of p1 but because
I'm calling a factory method I get to
apply an object initializer to it and so
I can create a modified copy for
instance when I got married I changed my
last name so I used to be called Nilson
but then I got married and now I'm
called Torgerson so we're creating a new
record of me that's like the old one but
with something changed I just
non-destructive mutation which is a key
element in working with with immutable
data and so this is using these
combination of elements I can now have
an immutable object that where I can
create when I can do non-destructive
mutation and you know maybe like with
the current object initializes maybe we
allow you to emit the arguments for
niceness when when the argument list is
empty or what we're currently planning
there's a there's a keyword that that's
syntactic sugar for doing what you just
saw that's a with expression that is
assigned for this very purpose for a
non-destructive communication so now
these building blocks let's go and talk
about what a record what a record
feature could be so let's imagine that
this is extra keyword that you can put
on a class a struct declaration you say
that it's a record and you declare some
properties and it has inheritance like
everything else but the record keyword
means that there are some things you get
well first of all even without the
record keyword we get nominal creation
because we have this
in it only property feature but on top
of that the record keyword automatically
generates that with stuff that was a
little gnarly an example before so when
you put record on it will it will just
put the right thing into the class to
support a non-destructive mutation so
that you can with these records here
also we didn't talk about that as a
separable
a separate feature but you could get
value equality so let's say very
hypothetically that I can divorced or
just changed my mind about my last name
you know there would be another
non-destructive mutation here and we
value equality would then mean that even
though P 3 reference is a different
object a different object identity than
the original P 1 then comparing them
equal with various equals and mechanisms
would still make them the same because
they contain the same values value
equality is also really useful when
you're just talking about plain old data
it's a little dangerous when you have
objects that are immutable but value
equality and immutable go really well
together and so we would also support
value equality out of the gate on
records getting implementing value
equality is yourself
is really tedious and it's also
error-prone and especially when you have
inheritance in the mix it's actually
really hard to to create or it's hard to
get it right to create an equality
implementation that is symmetric even
when there's inheritance involved tend
to accidentally compare things using the
left hand sides equality in some cases
and right hand sides equality in other
cases or rather if you swap them you get
different equality supply but we have a
trick for that and so we we know a good
way to implement value equality across
inheritance so we've been debating
whether value equality should be
something that you can
independently opt-in to on a class or
whether it should just be something we
do when you when you go fooling and say
I'm I'm on my class to be a record class
we haven't we our current plan of record
is plant record is to to just have value
quality generated for records because we
think records are broad and useful
enough that that it's fine that when you
want value of the quality you probably
want the other stuff as well we may be
wrong on that and we're designing value
of quality in such a way that it's
easily separable as a feature if we
decide that that's the right thing even
later even in a subsequent now there are
other things to think about for records
now the the the record syntax that we
have here is pretty terse in that you
only have to state the properties and
the rest gets figured out for you but of
course people can't get enough of
terseness right and so you you might
wonder whether there are some
abbreviations that you can do when you
have a record maybe you know maybe
things are probably by default and so
whenever you declare your properties
they're public by default because after
all a record is really about the data
and you wouldn't normally or having
things private would sort of not be the
best default maybe most records wouldn't
have any private stuff and only very
advanced ones would and so maybe just
changing the default would be good maybe
you want to go even even further and say
that if you declare something that just
looks like it what would be a private
field in normal class maybe that
actually defaults to generating a public
in it only property of that name and so
that things are so terse that you can
you can just write your types as
one-liners now it's almost like being in
a functional language but with beautiful
inheritance you get these very church
data declarations so where to where to
set the dial on this abbreviation stuff
is something that we're also it's an
active debate and they're still figuring
it out and again it's something that if
we don't do it upfront it's still going
to be really useful and we can add
later my public demand so that's up for
the suffer debate now you you might also
want to mix constructors and records and
it might be nice if you could declare a
record with sort of a constructor to
clear it directly on the class name and
just have these things turn into
properties to init only properties on
the person class as well as there being
a constructor generated for taking in
those we could even declare a
Deconstructor for you as well if you
have a constructor of course it has now
we're back to some of the same problems
with the positional creation that you
and I have to repeat yourself in a drive
class and so on right so this might be
something that you would mostly do if
you don't also have inheritance in the
mix but it's certainly on the table so
that was it for records and I'm gonna go
over and see if there are some there's a
question here and while I'm look while
I'm answering that maybe more questions
will come in will the nominal initialize
is still cover up the code line if an
error occurs say you use a method to set
a property that is the main reason I
don't use them cover up the code line
always meaning the sense of it in a
sense of tooling that you don't get the
the the place where the error occurs
called out as specifically there's
certainly if I'm understanding you
correctly for instance in the debugger
there are places where you can't really
the sub statement places where the
debugger can't really like step two and
you can't really get the feedback at
that level maybe when we've talked about
whether we should improve the tooling
here so I think maybe that is say if
that was the question maybe that is
something that we could could handle
angel just kind of wait another second
to see if there are more questions on
the records
you
there was a nullable question that I
missed maybe came in after I change
topics which I can I can come back to it
says Ken moving to Noble references be
automated somehow at least for most
cases that's a really good question I
think to some degree it probably can we
experimented with some tools and we did
try to use them on the on the core
library on our core libraries and I'm
not sure what the state of them are
they're certainly hacky but probably
things you could do to kind of do a
broad sweep and then get most of it
right
put malleability in accordingly so that
is that so me an option that the danger
of that is that you if you have any
wrong behavior in there you might end up
encoding that in the in the signature
rather than discovering it and fixing it
so they're trade offs there okay I am
not seeing more questions in slider
right now so let's move to the third
topic which is not something that we're
actively working on right now but that
we've been debating also for years and
it's one of those things that would be a
really big change to c-sharp that would
into c sure that would involve the
runtime and various things if something
that needs a lot of means a lot of
working through making sure we get it
right but I think it's very exciting if
there are people out there who are
acquainted with certain functional
languages maybe one of the ways of
looking at it is it's sort of an attempt
to add equivalent to what Haskell calls
type classes to c-sharp but I'm not
gonna explain it from that angle because
most of you are probably not Haskell
programmers and so that's not going to
be very enlightening but the the idea is
to add a triple of features to some
version of c-sharp which I will call ten
but that does not entail any sort of
promise or decision and and those would
help especially but not exclusively with
generic abstraction so the first feature
is static interface members so
interfaces today and in most
object-oriented languages can only
specify instance members for the
implementing classes roles is an idea of
allowing an existing value like an
existing object
viewing it from a certain angle and
giving it that it might imbue it with
additional members and also even
additional types without messing with
what how its represented at runtime like
without wrapping it or anything and
extensions are sort of a type level
version of that like extension methods
but allowing not just methods but other
things to apply to a given type in a
given scope in addition to what the type
already has and they're all kind of tied
together in various ways and I have an
example that I'll go through that
showcases all of them it's a little
contrived but on the other hand it
addresses a a common need that in in the
net code that is not well handled today
so so in that sense it shows some of
what these features will be able to do
okay so starting out with an interface
here one of the things that we really
struggle with this numeric abstraction
internet because numerix is done through
is typically done primarily with static
members in particular operators it's
really hard to abstract generically
algorithms that work on types that have
certain numeric capabilities but if we
had static members and interfaces we
could describe we could describe numeric
entities more abstractly with interfaces
like this so this is a mathematical
object called a monoid and we're
representing with an interface and a
monoid is something that has a neutral
element which we'll call zero and it has
an operator which applies to mono i'ts
and produces to the particular kind of
Monroy dan produces other objects of
that particular kind of mon line and of
course the serie one is then expected to
be neutral under under the-- what we
call the addition the Oberoi
and so based on just these two
operations we could we could write
ourselves a generic method that takes
anything that's a monoid takes an array
of those and starts out with the neutral
element and then she reaches over the
array and adds the the additional
elements whatever they are to that
accumulating it and then returning the
result course this is very this is a
trivial America algorithm but imagine
bigger numeric algorithms and imagine
bigger types representing their
capabilities now we we get a way of
writing a beautiful generic code
extracted or when you write capabilities
so I think so static members in and of
themselves are pretty useful and now we
would go and implement I'm annoyed on
say the ordinary int in a net and we
would add either an implicit or explicit
implementation of zero and we would sort
of just let the plus event implement the
plus operator expected by the I'm on our
interface and and now we would be able
to call this generic add all method with
an int array and infer the the type
argument to the int and it would satisfy
the constraint that it is indeed and I'm
on right of int so that kind of all
clicks together that's a story in and of
itself and it's really nice and so we
should just have static members and
interface in fact several years ago we
did an experiment of how to implement
that in the runtime and that turned out
exceedingly well except back then we
weren't eager to put new language
features in the run time because the
doesn't everyone time shift is part of
Windows and updating it was a nightmare
that we didn't want to embark on but now
we've done that core we can so let's go
an embrace that however there are also
some problems with this scenario and I'm
going to exaggerate them a bit just to
sufficiently motivate the other features
but let's have a look at it one problem
is that you can imagine many many
different sets of operators being being
embodied in interfaces and putting all
of them on hint would be like groups and
rings and all kinds of mathematical
objects plus more than you could come up
with yourself and we would have to put
all those in in and it will sort of have
too many interfaces for it to be
reasonable and be hard to predict which
one we should put on there another
problem is that there's more than one
way that it could actually implement
this interface like the natural the
obvious one is with with 0 and with the
inter plus operator but ink but integers
are actually a mono over multiplication
as well with a neutral element being one
and the and the operator being
multiplication and so we could equally
well not equally well because that's
more contrived but we could imagine
perfectly valid implementation of I'm
why not I'm on edge on hints that uses
that one and multiplication as as the
implementation so how do we choose in
this case it's probably obvious but some
K you can imagine cases where it's not
so obvious third problem is you know I
might want int to implement I'm on out
of team but I might not have access to
go in and muck with a core library here
I can't go and slap interfaces on it so
it'll kind of have to funnel through
some like central acceptance process oh
yes this is a good interface let's put
it in the core library and haven't
implemented em it's kind of like I'm I
don't get to muck with that as as a
numeric programmer who wants to use once
to abstract do something abstractly over
certain and numeric types so that's more
like a software engineering challenge as
well so let's try to solve that and the
idea is to have something called a roll
and I'm not going to
quibble about syntax this is definitely
a strawman syntax is if we ever do it it
will not look like this
what a roll is a new kind of type
declaration it declares a new kind of
thing which can enhance other types with
additional behavior so I'm going to
declare a roll that enhances int with
the neutral element 0 thus that's static
property ok
and now that means that I can sew this
in to add mono which has a 0 but the
role is something that is it's a type
that I can apply to ends so and it's not
representation changing so I can
actually take in a whole array of int
and I can just cast it to this into
admin oi type because it's a role on end
and that doesn't you know create a new
array and copy things over anything it's
really just a reference assignment it's
just another view type view that I have
on the same values that's what a role
means and but because I'm doing that I
can now view my int values as as into
admin rights if it added any instance
members I could loop over the this array
here and I could do things to my values
that in admin I added to them that
weren't inherit can't but roles could
even implement interfaces so it could
implement the I'm annoyed interface for
int and say that when you view int as
this role then they implement this
interface now and again just just like
the implementation of the interface
before it works the same way checks to
see ok doesn't have all the operations
well it has the plus but we need to
specify the 0 as well and now it does
have all the operations to apply in the
interface so when viewed as an int add
Mahanoy
and int is a monoid and this is how the
role specifies that that's the case and
how it's the case by giving the
implementations here and now the
interesting thing is that because of
that once
I view my end array as an array of int
ad monoids I can pass that to a doll and
the role becomes the type argument and
the type argument is therefore something
that satisfies the constraint that has a
plus and a zero and the generic method a
run so essentially what I've built is an
adapter for intz for them to fit into my
generic abstraction an adapter that does
that does not adapt them at runtime by
changing their representation but just
adapts into the type system if you will
so so that's what roles can do they can
adapt individual values or like arrays
of values here so that they fit certain
shapes or certain types now one of the
things that you can do with that because
I'm choosing which role to apply here is
that I could implement that other that
could you implement that other
implementation of mono it's unint
using a different role so I have an
in-mold Mahanoy here maybe there should
be better naming conventions for these
and and that also implements I'm on a
light event but in a different way gives
that those the multiplication based
implementation and now both can coexist
and be part of my toolbox so to speak
and then when I choose to pass my int
array to at all I can i specify with the
with the type parameter or the type
argument which which role I want to
apply like how my hints are gonna play
the role of I'm on our gets to be
specified there so I can I can do one
with in malmo noid instead here call the
same method with the same array has a
different role and get a different
result
now sometimes that's what you want
sometimes you want to be able to view
individual values through a certain lens
and sometimes what you want is just to
extend in a certain part of your program
you want to extend a given type with
extra capabilities and that's what we've
had extension methods for for many years
now
the problem with extension methods is
that they're sort of like an
evolutionary dead end in that based on
how they've done you can't really have
extension properties and extension much
else and so this is sort of an attempt
to back off that particular design but
use the general concept and introduce a
more a more generalized version of the
feature that we call extensions and what
an extension is is it's like a role it
specifies an enhancement of a given type
but it but it causes that enhancement to
apply to all values of that type
implicitly just like an extension as it
applies to all values of the type that
it enhances so it's just a
generalization of the extension method
concept so now all ends are employed in
the scope of this declaration wherever
this declaration has been put into
effect like has been using or whatever
and so now I can get the zero off of in
my knife but I can also get it off of
int because all intz on out in tonight's
endeavor have the zero static property
and again because this is just
essentially a role defined for all ends
I can implement interfaces with it and
now all int as long as this declaration
is enforced so to speak all intz are now
mono it's and can be passed to a doll
here so this would allow essentially the
full generalization of extension methods
not just to extension all other kinds of
members but also to extension interfaces
to extend with implementation of extra
interfaces and and that's it so we have
time for a few more questions
and I see that there are a few let's see
which use cases do you use for static
interfaces where do you see it being
used I think that numeric abstraction is
one another thing is if you want to
abstract over construction how the how
this kind of object can be constructed a
constructor is essentially a static
member so you could the interface could
specify that certain constructors are
present or factory methods it's things
like that that would be another big
scenario for it let's see there was a
question for the previous topic I
imagine for some classes I would want to
have both mutable and immutable
instances why not have them specified at
create instead eg new person as record
that's an interesting idea that's sort
of the idea that a given class can
specify both sometimes you you do that
you have that pattern where you can you
take things for a while and then you
freeze them and the only way you can
implement that today is to have a bit
inside of an object saying I'm freezed
and then start throwing on all the
mutation stuff and maybe you could build
that kind of thing into the type system
as well we haven't thought of that but
that might be an avenue you're thinking
I haven't thought of it much but yeah
good idea
any more questions
also on the are you just completely you
know you just want to get beer and
whatever time zone you're in see think
we have
seconds left of the talk I don't see
more things coming in even with the lag
we should conclude that you guys are you
guys are ready to the end of the day so
I want to say thank you very much for
listening to my crazy ramblings and you
know keep using c-sharp and keep getting
us the good ideas and the bad ones and
everything in between so we can keep
evolving it as a great language thank
you very much